Господи, дорог не будет?
Так підсумував герой Володимира Зеленського Василь Голобородько із серіалу "Слуга народу"
свої спроби відремонтувати дороги в Україні.
Чиновники змінювалися, бо розкрадали бюджет, і нічого не робилося.
Нині ж, будучи реальним президентом, Зеленський теж заповзявся,
як і його попередники, побудувати добрі дороги в Україні.
Я впевнений, що до кінця своєї каденції ми добудуємо всі державні дороги.
Я хотів би бути президентом, якого запам’ятають як людину,
після якої в України з’явилися дороги.
Я дуже цього хочу.
Володимир Зеленський ініціював програму "Велике будівництво".
За словами президента, у 9 разів збільшено протяжність доріг, які побудують цього року,
і це близько чотирьох з половиною тисяч кілометрів.
За даними Укравтодору, на більшій половині автошляхів роботи вже ведуться.
Справді окремі ділянки вже ремонтують. І про це активно знімають ось такі відеоролики.
Піару багато, а чи буде помітний результат, поки під питанням.
Президент регулярно навідується з інспекціями.
Це один з останніх візитів - на Хмельниччину, де обіцяють вже цього року
оновити понад 200 кілометрів доріг державного значення.
Дороги ж місцевого значення - а таких більшість в Україні
і це понад 117 тисяч кілометрів - у найгіршому стані.
За словами Зеленського, після місцевих виборів у його політичної сили
буде більше впливу на місцях, і "слуги народу" нарешті відремонтують дороги.
Також обіцяють знайти три мільярди доларів для оновлення всіх мостів України
та будівництва нових.
Щоправда, експерти зауважують: немає сенсу будувати дороги,
які одразу розбивають перевантажені фури, на вагу яких траси не розраховані.
Проблема в тім, що досі на українських дорогах немає
належного контролю за вагою вантажівок.
Майже кожна друга фура, що їздить українськими автошляхами, перевантажена.
Вагові комплекси мало де працюють.
Перевізники за хабарі можуть спокійно їздити на своїх перевантажених фурах,
фактично знищуючи дороги.
Крім того, через недоліки у залізничних вантажних перевезеннях -
а саме нестачу і поганий стан вагонів та локомотивів -
чимало вантажів перекладаються із залізничного транспорту
на автомобільний, що відповідно додатково збільшує навантаження на дороги.
Уряд має намір з 1 жовтня збільшити кількість інспекторів, які чергуватимуть на автошляхах,
на 200 осіб - хоча й цього буде замало для належного контролю.
Також обіцяють розширити мережу автоматичного вагового контролю.
Нині діє лише 9 таких комплексів, а з жовтня має бути 78.
Планується також змінити законодавство, щоб місцева влада теж могла встановлювати
комплекси габаритного контролю і частину штрафів
спрямовувати до місцевих бюджетів на відновлення доріг.
Зеленський обіцяє, що попри економічну кризу і карантинні обмеження
згортання великих програм дорожнього будівництва не буде.
Уряд також звітує, що попри екстренне формування фонду на боротьбу з COVID-19
вдалося збільшити кількість коштів у бюджеті на програму дорожнього будівництва,
і цього року на це виділять понад 100 мільярдів гривень,
запевняє прем’єр Денис Шмигаль.
При цьому експерти радять не лише рапортувати про збільшення фінансування,
а й дієво боротися з корупцією в цій сфері.
Бо через обмежену кількість підрядників в Україні часто мають місце картельні змови,
і відповідно завищується вартість будівництва та ремонту доріг.
Немає справжньої конкуренції в дорожній галузі,
а іноземні компанії пускають на цей ринок дуже неохоче.
Крім того, досі немає належного і системного контролю за якістю збудованих доріг.
Лише такий комплексний підхід дозволить якісно і на тривалий час
поліпшити стан українських доріг.